sept autres sujets qui posent problème
l'école la rentrée scolaire en septembre
risque d'être très compliqué après plus
de cinq mois sans cours est-ce que de
décrochage scolaire sont accrues
notamment en la légion et plus
défavorisés pour éviter de telles
conséquences le gouvernement réfléchit à
assouplir les règles sanitaires dans les
établissements scolaires des cils
atteint jean pour accélérer le retour
des élèves en classe ont un parent
direct avec michel fize les sociologues
auteur de l'ouvragé l'école à la ramasse
l'éducation nationale en faillite aux
éditions archipel
monsieur fils merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors première
question faut-il assouplir les règles
sanitaires dans les écoles elle c'est
une question très compliquée on le voit
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
on est allé à tâtons depuis le bout le
mois de mars et l'école ne fait pas
exception à cette règle
bon il est évident que plusieurs choix
était possible soit rester dans la
situation des cols fermés et d'attendre
tranquillement la rentrée de septembre
alors en permettant tête aux élèves les
plus défavorisés d'avoir un soutien par
le relais associatif par exemple un ou
par les associations sportives
bon donc il est vrai qu'il ya toujours
un risque de contagion même même faible
mais je crois aussi que la logique
actuelle et dans le sens de encore une
fois de l'allègement de l'allègement des
contraintes
donc je pense qu'il faut sans doute
essayer d'alléger un peu plus pour
permettre peut-être à davantage d'élèves
de faire ce retour en classe et puis
j'ai vu cet appel des pédiatres il ya
quelques semaines
cet appel des pédiatres envoyer les
enfants à l'école selon eux les enfants
s'offre au plus du confinement de la
mise à l'isolément que ducobu 19
je pense que les enfants ont besoin de
sociabilité c'est un âge où on a besoin
de retrouver ses camarades 1
filles et garçons d'ailleurs quand on a
interrogé les enfants confinés tous
disaient que pour eux il était important
de retourner à l'école
alors non pas tant pour les cours mais
précisément pour retrouver pour
retrouver leurs camarades
donc c'est vrai que la difficulté c'est
d'essayer d'ajuster un double impératif
protéger les enfants du virus d'une part
et puis permettent un retour à des
conditions normales de sociabilité donc
je crois qu'il faut avancer peut-être
encore un peu mais avec prudence et
comment justement vous évaluer la
reprise des cours depuis mois de mai
depuis qu'a commencé le déconfinement
belge coûté bon je ne suis pas certain
que cette réouverture des classes était
une une formidable idée parce que les
conditions sont tellement anormal que
l'on se demande finalement à quoi
servent ces heures de cours parce que
finalement un élève volontaire va
quelques heures en cours
chaque jours voire quelques heures
quelques heures par semaine donc je
regrette par rapport au constat que
j'avais fait la dernière donc d'un
effondrement dû système et un
effondrement structurelles et pas
simplement cet effondrement conjoncturel
lié à la crise pas qu'on aurait pu
innover d'ailleurs travail en petits
groupes
travailler sans être arrimés au
programme
voilà c'était des bonnes idées je pense
qu'on aurait dû vraiment révolutionné
l'école à partir de cette opportunité
que nous offrez paradoxalement cette
crise sanitaire
malheureusement on doit pas dans cette
direction la fragilité de l'école en
france on en parle on en parlait bien
avant la crise du coronavirus oui bien
sûr je pense qu'il faut tout revoir
comme je les ai écrit dans mon livre
indue du sol au plafond
bon plus personne ne s'est véritablement
à quoi il sert on est accroché au
programme comme un désespéré à sa bouée
de sauvetage
moi je me réjouis par exemple que le bac
2020 n'est pas eu lieu
voilà ça aurait peut-être été une bonne
idée pour poursuivre dans cette voie et
imaginer des solutions d'évaluation
continue pas feint pas forcément des
notes 1 pas forcément un contrôle comme
on le fait traditionnellement mais
vraiment évaluer les compétences là dans
le cadre de petits groupes
à mon avis c'est l'école de demain qu'on
a là et c'est assez curieux qu'en
période de crise on est en train de
dessiner une école du futur et on va
revenir à l'école d'avant
dès la rentrée de septembre monsieur
fise merci d'avoir a conduit à nos
questions rappelle que vous êtes
sociologue auteur de beaux ouvrages
l'école à la ramasse l'éducation
nationale en faillite a retrouvé aux
éditions archipel merci